hey guys I'm with Bobby on Oak arowana
who scored nine drawers here in the
London chess classic now that we've
wrapped up the first season to the Grand
Chester or what are your impressions of
this event uh I think the tour was was
fantastic um it was very interesting and
even now it's not clear who's who's
going to win it um my own play was
unremarkable um I mean nine drawers
isn't the best record but at least I I
mean I missed some Chancellor's but at
least in near the end I think I played
okay at least you didn't lose like
Magnus said um and what do you think of
what's gonna happen tonight what is your
prediction um well I think that Magnus
has good chances to win mm-hmm and now
put it on plus two um and I'm not sure
what will happen in a roni investor
lagrave um I think you are running is
pressing but it's not easy it's probably
probably going to end in a draw but he
has some chances to win either way that
would be a three-way playoff though yeah
yeah it's going to be um I don't know
the exact grant two points or a in any
case it would be a three-way either of
those two potential things and unless
Magnus doesn't win um yeah it's gonna be
really close to all I'll watch it with
interest if you were involved in a
playoff and you had to compete against
these guys in a non chess activity what
activity would you pick uh I'm not
really good at any sports um I'd say
trivia I'll manage enough trivia I like
that okay so get your jeopardy questions
ready for fabiano caruana I'm always
great to have him here on the tour and
we will send it back to you guys in the
studio as we wait for the games to
conclude